i'm gonna talk about why apple should be  worried about the new snapdragon 8 gen 1  and the mediatek 9000 because if they  don't act fast and fix the current  biggest problem with the iphone chip  design then the iphone 14 pro is gonna  be in huge trouble the number one thing  that's holding back the performance of  apple's iphone chips is overheating and  thermal throttling while that new  snapdragon chip isn't coming anywhere  close to apple in terms of cpu benchmark  scores the graphics side of the chip is  incredible the new chip was actually  able to outperform the a15 and 3dmark's  wildlife benchmark which is mind-blowing  because the iphone was already almost  twice as fast as the previous  competition but making things worse the  new mediatek 9000 chip got a huge  improvement in terms of multi-core cpu  performance outperforming every other  android phone chip on the market and is  the first chip to beat out the iphone 12  lineup